uh so our next speaker you know we're
super super happy to have uh gabrielle
farina here to tell us about his work on
uh extensive forget form games so uh
yeah i'll let you uh
let you get started
all right thanks so much um
i know if you are still offering the
moderating the chat kind of kind of
package but okay thanks i appreciate it
yeah i appreciate that
all right well hi everybody uh well
thanks so much for being here um you
know like like dion said i'll be talking
about uh extensive from games but you
know like maybe from a very kind of like
online learning point of view um so you
know like no you know like knowledge of
accessible games is necessary to
understand what i'll be talking about
um
and you know i'll be talking
specifically about a paper uh that you
know like it's like joint work with uh
chengwei i think encryption and they put
like a link also in the like the
description on the website
all right i guess um
all right well
i guess you know like the starting point
for for this talk is this realization
that at this point we know a lot about
uh neurogram learning in normal form
games right so learning in the context
of normal form games has been studied
extensively if you're not familiar with
number one games what i mean here is
kind of like
strategic interactions in which every
player acts simultaneously and once
every player has a set of actions uh
they just like pick one action their
utility depends on the
uh like tuple of auctions that were
chosen by all the players
and you know it's kind of like one of
the the bedrocks of
game theory and the reason why
uh you know like there has been so much
interest in our great learning or at
least one of the reasons is this
landmark result in the theory of
learning games which says that when all
players learn using
neurograd dynamics then the empirical
frequency of play converges to the set
of course correct equilibria which
basically says that learning which is a
very per player local kind of behavior
can induce kind of like global game
theoretic you know notions of
equilibrium
and you know like i it doesn't really
matter actually what nor get dynamics
you use as long as they're not good
enough which means that they uh
guarantee kind of like the the regret
girl subliminally so in in the slide i
have for example multiplicative with
update i will talk about a lot about
that specific algorithm but this result
is actually so powerful that you know it
doesn't really depend on one specific
algorithm and in fact you can also mix
and match different algorithms for
different agents you don't really need
to know how other agents are learning
uh
you know there's even more to this like
you know here i mentioned when all
players learn using inorganics and this
applies to
you know like the the blue box applies
to multiplayer genres some games but you
know like if you have two player
zero-sum games in particular then you
can get even stronger results so for
example like the average uh strategies
converge to the set of nash equilibrium
and you know of course there's like
multiple ways in which you can find this
equilibria which do not include learning
for example like if you have a two
players or some game you could use um i
know just like uh linear programming for
example but um you know as of today this
approach using learning is by far the
most scalable way of computing game
theoretic solutions and equilibrium
large games and you know even from an
engineering point of view there are good
reasons for this um like these dynamics
have linear time strategy updates which
means that when you know the the set of
auctions for the players is very large
uh like like updates of the like in this
like learning dynamics are still very
efficient every agent learns a parallel
so if you have more agents you can just
run you know like their dynamics in
parallel um and also uh like at least in
theory you know like in many cases you
can do learning by only looking at the
utility of a specific player and each
player does not care about the utility
of all the other players right so you
can learn
like uncoupled way what it was called
right so this is like useful for example
if you're trying to deploy just like
learning dynamics when you don't really
know the utilities of all the other
agents right so it has like all of these
good properties and because of all of
these good properties it's perhaps not
surprising that over the past decade
faster and faster and our great dynamics
have been developed for normal form
games
and at this point i mean this is like
debatable i guess but i i i feel like
confident in saying that you know like
the most started algorithm probably for
for the task of like normal from games
is optimistic multiplicity with updates
kind of like the the one also with the
strongest property um and you know like
in in terms of like properties that it
guarantees it's like some incredibly
strong properties like for example when
all the players learn using optimistic
multiplicity weights update then uh you
can show that uh the uh the regret of
each individual agent grows
algorithmically over time which is
actually kind of like a recent result by
castis i think i think you talked
extensively about about this and this in
this kind of program here at simon's um
at the same time you know like not only
the dependence on time is polarity but
also the dependence on the number of
actions is polar algorithmically it's
very logarithmic uh right so like
already this just like this first like
big bullet point immediately implies
that when you use optimistic
multiplicative weights update in
normal frame games you converge to a
course to the set of course graded
equilibria install play at that rate of
roughly utility one or t
um
but there's even more uh you know like
not only the per player regrets the
regret is slow but also the sum of the
player regrets you can show is even
stronger so for example uh instead of
even polygonally in time like the red
actually doesn't grow with with respect
to time like it's like constant with
respect to time um and again there's
like a
logarithmic dependence on a number of
actions
and furthermore you know like this
optimistic multiplicity weights update
has come like last strategy convergence
into players or some there's like some
caveats i feel like we don't really have
not really cracked as a community like
that kind of like problem of last
strategy convergence quite yet there are
like some results that require some
particular scheduling of step sizes or
they require kind of like uniqueness of
nash but you know like by and large i
feel like it's interesting that there's
like this one algorithm for normal from
games
that you know can achieve all of these
properties and you know i feel like at
this point for normal form games we have
really like a good answer as to what it
means to learn effectively
however
normal form games are a rather limited
model of strategic interaction as we
said you know like they
uh require all players to act once and
simultaneously and therefore you know
like they have no support for modeling
say sequential actions or observations
about other players options right so we
know a lot about what it means to learn
from normal from games but often normal
from games are not really a model of a
strategic interaction that's rich enough
for us
so a different model of
strategic interaction that is
significantly more expressive is
extensive form games right so
fundamentally the difference between
normal form games and extensive games is
that normal form games they're like one
shot like every player acts
simultaneously once whereas in extensive
form games every player instead faces a
three-form decision problem and this
three-form decision problem has both
decision points and observation points
where the agent instead like waits to
see to like to observe a signal from the
environment
um and because of this kind of like a
more expressive true form kind of like
structure that can capture both
sequential and simultaneous moves as
well as imperfect information and also
they can model explicitly stochastic
moves such as like you know like you
observe a roll of the dice for example
um right so they are a very expressive
model of interaction and you know like
pretty much all the recreational games
you can think about can be easily
modeled and have been historical models
as you can see from games like chess
poker uh bridge but then of course
there's like also non-recreational
interactions like for example security
games maybe sequential auctions there's
like you know like it's it's a very
general uh formalism
right so just just to fix some ideas as
to you know like to see how an extensive
decision problem
uh works you know like for example here
i have
uh the uh decision problem that is faced
by the first player in [ __ ] poker which
is not like a simplified version of kuhn
version of poker and the way the
interaction works is that the
interaction starts at the root uh this
is like player one so player one has an
observation point they can observe
whether their private card is a jack a
queen or king because there's an
observation point say that they observe
that it's a jack then the interaction
for that player moves to a decision
point and now they have to decide what
they want to do and maybe they want to
check maybe they want to race it doesn't
really matter like if you don't know
what it means before it's just like two
auctions um right so say that they
decide to check at this point they can
observe what the opponent is doing maybe
the opponent is in turn checking or
maybe opponent is raising they just say
that the opponent checks well at that
point you know like the three has
finished so the interaction has ended
and there's maybe some payoff that that
the player will observe for example if
it's a showdown and you know like they
won twenty dollars
right so it doesn't really matter uh you
know like what the actions were if you
don't know what poker is all the only
thing that matters is that uh in an
extensive form game every player faces
this kind of three-form decision problem
that is made of two types of notes you
have decision points where the decision
maker picks one action out of a set of
available actions and then you have
observation points where the decision
maker observes a signal drawn from a set
of possible signals and decision
observation points formation
okay
and again you know like uh we're talking
about game so you know every player is
facing some of this so it's not like an
mdp or three mdp where you know like you
have some stationary environment every
player is facing this kind of like
decision problem and you know like the
observations they receive will change
over time when when the game is repeated
and not just in an adversarial way
right so there's a fundamental question
as to you know before we can do any type
of learning over extensive form uh games
how do we even represent strategies like
it's not perhaps a priori 100 obvious
how you would represent uh like
strategies in a way that is optimization
and learning friendly like for you know
like for normal form games like rock
paper scissors recorded me as like a
strategy it's like a distribution of
reactions they want to play uh when you
have a three there's like multiple
things that you can do and number of
them are equally good but the good news
is that there exists a way of
representing strategies in accessible
games so that two things happen the
first thing is that each player's
strategy set is a low-dimensional
complex polytope which is called the
sequence from polytope and the utility
functions are multi-linear which means
that at least like if you just like
squint your eyes and just look at the
kind of like analytic kind of like
structure of solving an extension from
game it's not very different from a
normal form game
right so in particular because we have
this kind of like convex polytopes of
action or like or strategies and
multi-linear utility functions this
enables online learning access from
games as well as other complex
optimization techniques so for example
you can do online you know gradient
descent you can do mirror descent you
can do a lot of things
um right so this seems all good but the
reality is that
you know like online learning results
for example games are harder to come by
and this is due to the more intricate
strategy set so we said for a normal
from game we only have a simplex we know
a lot of things about simplices um but
for example games we have these kind of
like more complicated polytubes which
have a very
kind like combinatorial structure and
you know it's it's hard
sometimes to
be able to show like properties that you
care about that you can attain in normal
form games in extensive games so for
example you know earlier i was talking
about optimistic multiplicative weights
and all the strong properties that it
possesses and you know an extension from
games it's not known that you can
achieve uh those properties sometimes
you know like it's not known that you
can achieve them like individually uh
let alone you know just like achieving
all of them at the same time
right so for many years the extensive
forum game community and this is like
you know like personal opinions so you
know it's just like it disappearable but
my you know like
understanding of of you know like the
extension from game community is that
you know for many years
the extensive game community has been
chasing the normal form game community
trying to extend breakthroughs and
properties that were known to be
achievable in normal form games to
extensive from games when it was
possible sometimes it's not possible
sometimes since your games are harder um
and you know as kind of like a proof of
this i have like some examples here of
uh kind of like techniques or tools that
were all developed later for example
from games
than normal from games uh and sometimes
even only with weaker guarantees so we
you know like it took a long time to get
good distance measures like notions of
projections for example for these more
structured poly types of like tree form
strategies
uh it took some time to get efficient
optimistic algorithms um velocity
convergence like still way less is known
compared to normal from games
and in fact even more proof like this
paper was actually born from our desire
to extend the poverty regret bound that
was proven by you know christies and and
and noah knox uh in in europe 21 21 to
extend it from games right like we saw
that there was like this breakthrough
where now you could guarantee polygamic
regret when all the players were using
the same learning dynamic and and that
was only for normal from games and there
was like this natural question can we do
it in the kind of like more rich class
of extensive games
right so
i'll tell you the answer like the answer
is yes we can but for the first time at
least we're not really chasing uh you
know just like by trying to adopt
techniques but instead we will reduce
extensive form to normal form directly
right and in particular we will answer
this question as to does it have to be
like this does it have to be like
extensive from game community always
chasing the normal from game community
right or can we somehow bridge the gap
and inherit like the best properties of
normal form games
for extensive form games
and at least conceptually
there you might think that there is hope
for that right like there's a full core
result that says that every time you
have a an extensive game which means you
know like every player faces like a tree
from decision problem well you can
convert it into an equivalent normal
form game where basically what you do is
that you enumerate all the deterministic
strategies on the tree and then you
build this kind of like big kind like
matrix game or normal form game um
where kind of like the actions
correspond to kind of like full
strategies in the tree um right so if
you convert your extensive game into
normal from game using that and then you
use for example optimistic
multiplicative weights update then
you know you you are able to get all of
those like strong guarantees such as for
example like pologramic regret but of
course there's a catch which is that the
number of uh deterministic strategies or
policies in uh these kind like three
form decision problems is exponential in
the in each player's tree size which
means that when you go and use
optimistic multiplicative weights on
this kind like expanded game then you
will not have uh polynomial iterations
right and it was a common reason for a
long time that because of this
exponential blow up this approach was a
computational dead end and as a
consequence like i said you know like
specialized techniques were developed
for extension from games and progressed
some extension from games and normal
form games historically followed several
tracks for decades
i mean the number of rounds often plays
logarithmic even the number of uh
deterministic strategies
which is like the height of the team in
the normal game
of
actions right
like in principle like are you talking
about the computation programs here or
exactly about
the number of rounds right i'm talking
about the computation for rounds right
but you're right like those dynamics
like you said like for for gamers
independence of number of actions so
this gives even more hope that it could
be possible to kind of like you know
just like somehow try to simulate fast
and still
get good regret and this is actually
exactly what the world maker is about so
i don't know that sub game perfect is
the most believable like it's not
not be sufficient for example
right so something perfect i guess
depends on that when they want to be
perfect information but like depending
on perfect information it might not be a
special equilibrium but actually some
games when like in in the technical
settings not even exist
okay so it doesn't really fix separate
sequentiality if speciality is what you
meant by the most believable
i think
to solve those kind of like issues of
nothing threats and like being robust
and parts of the game through that you
shouldn't reach if not like unless
somebody made a mistake uh so i'm not
sure that something but something
reflection definitely helps compared to
like just undefined dash but yeah like
this thing will not guarantee death as
well as something uh but also like i was
saying it's not clear that that's
actually the solution to the problem but
definitely
that's a good question yeah
um
right so
you like just to go back to this kind of
common wisdom you know like because the
exponential blob the above approach was
thought to be a computational dead end
for decades and it turns out that the
common reason was wrong right so this is
like what this paper is about will
actually show that you can reduce and
breach the chrome extensions from games
normal from games and bridge this gap
um
in an efficient way computationally
one related question so i guess
one
hopeful type of algorithm for normal
from games that you might hope to extend
to extensive form maybe it's like folded
for third leader
uh you know um
such a congressman being started out in
excess from games we we at some point
we're talking about like
[Music]
um
right so the common museum is wrong and
particularly in this paper what we show
is that it is possible to simulate
optimistic multiplicative weights on the
normal form equivalent of an extensive
fund gain in linear time per iteration
in the tree size via kernel trick and we
call this algorithm kernelized
optimistic multiplicative weights for
obvious reasons
and in fact this kernelized optimistic
multiplicative weight applies not only
to extension from games but to any
polyhedral domain with zero one
coordinate vertices
as long as of course you can compute the
the kernel efficiently um but we have
this main theorem that says that
basically optimistic multiplicative
weights on the set of vertices of of a
zero one coordinate uh like you know
polyhedral set omega can be simulated
using d plus one evaluations of the
kernel at each iteration where d is the
dimension in which you make a lift so
like critically you know like the number
of evaluations have not does not depend
on the number of vertices but only in
the dimension in which the pulled up
leaves which is kind of like the
important result
um and what this means
like immediately is that if each kernel
evaluation can be performed in time
polynomial intervention then optimistic
multiplicative weights can be simulated
in temporal normal dimension
and when you just look at the specific
case of accidents from games and like we
said kernel is optimistic multiplicative
weights closes part of this gap between
learning in these two domains and you
know just like it achieves all the
strong properties
of optimistic multiplicative weights
update uh they were so far only known to
be achievable in normal form games
including the prologue regret that uh
christian and his group worked on as
well as any future regret bounds that
might get proven for optimistic
multiplicative words update because at
this point it's not like we're taking an
algorithm modifying it and then you know
just like showing a bound we're just
using the same algorithm that people
have been studying and refining analysis
for so if somebody tomorrow comes up and
says hey wait actually it's not locked
to the 4t but it's locked to the second
t
or like or just like block t or even
just a constant then you know we would
inherit all of that for example from
games directly so i think there's like
this like added value that we are not
introducing a new algorithm we're just
simulating one efficiently
and on top of all of this there's also
something else that surprised us which
surprised that surprised us which is
that as
unexpected by product kernelized
optimistic multiplicative weights
obtains new state-of-the-art regret
bounds among all of the online learning
algorithms for extensive form problems
right so there have been a lot of
research as to how do you build uh kind
like efficient you know linear time
regression for example uh online
learning methods for extension from
games and you know regret bounds were
known and then it turns out that
just by simulating optimistic
multiplicative weights you just like do
better than like decades of research on
like specialized methods for extensive
games so not only the common wisdom was
wrong right but but when you can like
violate it you know like you get extra
properties and also improve on the
regret bound compared to anything else
i see in particular
this is like not important but just like
to point out some of the improvements
that that uh criminalized multiplicative
weights and optimistic multiplicative
you know like if you look at the
dependence on the like l1 diameter of
the strategy space we have kind of like
a square root dependence on the exponent
right so like if earlier it was exponent
one like for example in the first class
of algorithms then now we have a square
root and if the earlier exponent was two
now we have a just like a one at the
exponent right and like i said you know
like we also have near optimal uh
algorithmic regret bounds inherited from
acousticism and max and noah's analysis
yeah so the
yeah the line separates um
the non-optimistic methods from the
optimistic methods
right and it's kind of interesting that
um
i mean i'm not aware of like matching
lower bounds or anything but like
usually
the kind of dependence on the size is
squared if you want optimism okay so
this is actually like yes as far as i
know like like an open question still
has to if that's tight or not but
um
it's kind of like interesting that you
know we have the separation and the you
know like if you want optimism then you
have to pay
a bigger cost
all right okay so i guess that concludes
from like the introduction so now you
know what's in the paper um and now i
guess we can dig deeper a little bit
into uh some of the technical bits that
make this result possible so i'll start
with some preliminaries uh i'll talk a
little bit about online learning and
normal form games i just assume that
most of us are familiar so i'll go a
little bit fast but you know online
learning fundamental ah sorry yeah sorry
just before we go into the
i guess
um
what exactly are we learning here
what is the appropriate
delivery concept of this accelerating or
that's that's no that's a destination
version um this will be for course
related equipment
um there's also like uh obligations for
nash in for people users but i mean that
the thing is that's not surprising
but yeah that's not the same question
there's another question as to how can
we learn fast for other types
[Music]
i guess we've done some work also with
justice about
small progress for example
um but that's phenomenal from the engine
it's not clear if you can finalize that
algorithm for example for example games
right so there's a lot of open questions
here
um
right so we're talking about online
learning uh right video of online
learning is simple you know you
at least again it's most kind of like
basic form you have a set of a finite
set of actions a um and you consider the
following abstract model of decision
maker at every time t the decision maker
has to select the distribution over the
actions right so it's like some lambda t
of like convert combination coefficients
effectively over the set of actions so
it's like a vector a non-negative vector
indexed over action such that uh you
know like the sum of the mass that you
put on the action is equal to one
uh then what happens is that the
environment picks a reward vector um
which uh sorry i guess i uh that there's
a typo it's like r to the a right like
it's a it's a reward vector in the
dimensional number of auctions it
doesn't have to be non-negative
um and shows that reward vector to the
decision maker and finally you know like
the utility of the decision maker is
then the inner product between the
distribution that they selected over the
actions and the reward vector and then
the iteration continues right like and
over time what you want is you want the
regret which is defined as kind of like
the
you know like the difference between uh
how much you could have done if you if
you had always picked the best
distribution in hindsight minus how much
you've actually done in terms like some
of the actual uh utility for the
decision maker you want the this regret
to gross up linearly
uh right and in particular the reason
why you care about stability regret is
that
it's known that decision-making
algorithms that guarantee some linear
regret in time in the worst case
converged equilibrium games um and you
know like out of kind of like all the
algorithms that we know for this kind
like online learning problem the way i
defined it uh multiplicity weight update
is probably the most well studied
algorithm that has this property of
guaranteeing sublinear regret in the
worst case and i want to go through like
go over like how it works it's very
simple uh in the first iteration the
distribution lambda is completely
uniform right so it's just like one over
number of actions uh times the indicator
that times the vector one and then what
we do is that at a iteration we output
uh the
incumbent distribution we observe a
reward vector and then what we do is
that we update the distribution by
multiplying basically every
like probability that we had at the
previous step by kind of like a bonus
factor that is exponential in the reward
that that action got
okay so we just have this kind of like
you know every action will be now
selected with the previous probability
times
exponential of some step size parameter
times the reward that that action got at
the at the last round
and then of course we have to normalize
because we have to output a um like a
distribution
and you know like this is like like
multiplicative weights update the
optimistic version i've been talking
about a lot uh is obtained simply by
replacing this rt with you know just
like a different kind of like formula
um right and it's known that when you
use optimistic then you can unlock even
in the worst case like faster uh regret
bounds than what you can without the
optimism
um right like for this talk because it's
so easy to go from one to the other i
will always ignore optimism and uh you
know like all the techniques will apply
to uh optimism directly
all right so let me briefly talk about
normal form games at this point right
there like we said simultaneous uh
non-sequential games every player has a
final set of actions ai right so player
i have has a russian ai
um
and you know like the received and every
player receives a payoff that depends on
the combination of the actions that were
selected um the strategy for each player
is simple probability distribution over
direction and this idea of learning
games finally we can define it it's just
this idea that each player now plays
according uh to
uh like a learning algorithm like in the
way that we just defined it and after
each repetition the reward vector of
each agent is just the gradient of the
expected utility for that agent given
the strategy of all the other printers
right so now you can if you have a
normal form game you can
you know just like basically let all the
players play against each other by
giving each other that gradient of the
utility
and this is what people mean when they
say that they're learning in the game
so this is for normal form games but you
know like as i mentioned this talk is a
lot about extensive form games but you
know we'll obstruct extensions from
games we'll remove all of the
uh kind of like the nasty notation i
think accessible games the the thing
that they need the most is like a
notational breakthrough so instead we
will uh move to an even bigger class
that you know it's like uh you know it's
like a superset of extensive games which
is called polyhedral complex games and
very abstractly the idea of polyhedral
convex game is that in a polyhedral
convex game the set of strategies of
each player is given as a complex
polytope omega i right so like we said
in normal from game the set of
strategies is the probability
distributions over the set of actions
now instead we have a general convex
follow-up not just a simplex right so we
represent it as come like a tuple where
we have number of players the set of
actions and then we always will we will
always assume that the utility functions
are multi-linear this is always
guaranteed for uh normal form games just
like by kind of like definition of what
it means like for like expected utility
but here it just takes a little bit uh
like more care so like we'll assume that
the utility functions are multi-linear
and you know like the the interesting
thing about political convex games is
that if you take all the things that we
talked about for normal from games and
you now replace the probability like set
of probability distributions over
actions with just like the set omega i a
lot of things go through but in
particular the concept of learning agent
or regret you know like infography at
max over all probability distributions
over the over the actions now you have
max over all points in
uh omega i for example for player i like
everything just goes through
um which means that uh you know like we
can we can do learning and the reason
why we care about polyhedral convex
games is that extensive form games are
polyhedral complex games
right
so
basically for like for now for the rest
of the talk will not and until the end
will not talk about extension games but
rather we'll talk about political convex
games as are like on the like uh setting
and you will see that this current light
optimistic multiplicative weights
applies to all political complex games
whose kind like set of uh
strategies omega has integral vertices
right like in particular vertices that
have zero one coordinates
yep so
you know like in particular like we
expected from games we said oh we can
always kind of like enumerate the
strategies over the tree and then build
a bigger normal form game out of debt
well it turns out that this idea is not
unique to extensive games in all
political complex games you can always
uh you know convert them into an
equivalent normal form game
in which each player's action set in
this equivalent normal form game is just
a set of vertices right so when people
talk about the normal form equivalent of
an extension from gaming tacitly they're
basically what they're doing is that
they're just doing this more general uh
procedure where every time you have a
polyhedral compass game you can
enumerate the vertices and then build an
equivalent normal form game like where
each agent now has to pick out of the
set of vertices
and you can think about this as sort of
a change of variable like the like
learning in a polyhedral convex game
would have amounted to kind of like
learning how to pick points in the
polytope and instead
of picking points in the polygon now
you're learning to find convex
combination coefficients over the
vertices and you know because the sets
are convex you know it's known that you
can reach every point with an
appropriate convex combination right so
you're just like basically transforming
the problem over instead of picking
points in the in like in in your site
directly you just first speak complex
combination coefficients of vertices and
then you just like do learning over
there
in the extensive form the vertices are
deterministic tree form structures are
like normal form well reduced normal
form points
okay so if you view a reduced number of
one plane it's kind of like a a bit
string of zeros and one depending on
like the what sequences are active
uh then the setup all reduced normal
form plans is the set of vertices of the
sequence one volatile
right so
isn't it
[Music]
at this point i'm not talking about
efficiency but i'm just saying that
every for convex game can be converted
into the equivalent number one game by
just looking at the set of vertices
right like if you do that of course
you'll still pay extension prices just
because like if you get that in
particular in extensive games you would
compare it to all the problems that we
talked about
but what's what's interesting is that
you know like
the process at this point of learning in
in the normal form equivalent
um of a general usual complex game using
multiplicity weights update you can
think of it as multiplicity weights
update data tracks from that over the
vertices this is like the one that we
will care about so in particular we will
say we can simulate running
uh multiplicity with update on the
normal formula an accessible game what
we mean is that we are able to simulate
this vertex and w u algorithm
and you know like i i'll go over what it
does basically vertex and w u is just
like mw over a set of vertices so it
keeps track of something incumbent
distribution over the vertices at the
beginning it's the uniform distribution
uh where like the i87 setup is the
vertices of your
uh convex uh set of strategies from the
guide
and then what happens is that
at definition the we need to play a
point in omega and we'll play the point
that responds to the complex combination
from the right so we'll play the point x
t which is sum over the vertices of
problems of that vertex times that
vertex so we just play the complex
combination given by lambda and then
we'll serve we will observe a word
vector and then we will set
uh the new distribution using
the same formula that we had for
multiplicity which with the only
difference that um
you know like now you don't really have
uh kind of like the kind of like the
component of of the word vector that
corresponds the specification you have n
inner products right basically the only
difference with kind of like the regular
multiplicative weights is that there's
just like this inner product here
course the fact that we output uh
complex combinations
okay so
basically like for the rest of the talk
i'll just like try to convince you that
we can simulate this without actually
doing exactly what the steps are saying
like in particular we don't really have
to update our distribution vertex by
vertex
right but before we do that as usual you
know vertex optimistic multiplicative
weights is analogous uh you know just
like we said you know instead of the
the reward you use two times the reward
minus the previous reward uh everything
just goes through um and the other thing
that you know we should check is that
vertex omw it's immediate to see from
the analysis that you know just like uh
the the paperweight because this
annoying and max have guarantees poor
logarithmic
regret in respect to time when used by
all players to learn in a polyhedral
complex game
so the
main question of the paper again is can
vertex multiplicative weight of data or
optimistic multiplicative weights update
be simulated efficiently yes
yes yeah first things from games i'll
always assume for the people
um
okay so
the main theorem so i just like move
vertex
nothing has changed but the main theorem
is that when the set omega has zero one
coordinate vertices then vertex and w
can be implemented using d plus one
evaluation of a zero one polygonal
kernel a registration which i will talk
about in a second what it is but you
know again like crucially the important
thing here is that
the number of evaluations depends only
on the dimension and now the number of
vertices you can have polyhedral sets
with exponentially many vertices um but
as long as the dimension is low you can
stimulate this algorithm fast this is
what the main theorem says
okay so with that let me tell you a
little bit about what this zero one
point usual kernel is again like our
setup will be that we have a set omega
which is our
polytope uh v is a set of vertices and
we're assuming that the vertices are
have like zero one coordinates
so to define the kernel we'll first need
to define the zero one feature map of
omega right so the future map what it
does is that it maps a point in rd into
a point in r v where v is the set of
vertices we say right so like it kind of
blows up a vector and in particular if
you give any vector x in rd to this map
it will produce a vector
in rv where every comp every coordinate
that corresponds to any vertex p is just
defined as this kind of like product
that's basically what it does is that
given a vector for each vertex it
computes the product of the coordinates
that are hot for that vertex remember
that vertices are integral zero one
right so there's like it's well defined
what it means uh for a coordinate to be
hot it just means that in the vertex it
has a one right so it just computes the
product there
and once you have this the zero one
polyhedral kernel is you know just like
defined in the usual way right like as
the inner product between the kind of
like the feature maps of two points
so if you just plug in the definition
you get the second quality
that's a very simple very clean
definition of of the kernel in terms of
of like what the formula looks like
and i'll try to explain now how the
feature map and the kernel help simulate
vertex and w so what i did is i rewrote
like you know just copy pasted vertex
and w nothing has changed it was the
same algorithm um
and you know i also put the definition
of a feature map on the left again like
nothing has changed
there are two ideas that make you know
like this kind like simulation using the
kernel trick uh
like possible the first idea is this
lemma that says that actually these uh
points like this kind of like
distributions lambda have a lot of
structure and in particular at every
time t they're proportional to the
future map of a specific vector that we
give
right so this means that these
distributions lambda for the way they're
updated they cannot be too free right
they have a lot of structure
the proof is by induction the proof is
easy um and if you don't you know if you
don't really want to care about like
details and you only want to stay
connected at the high level what this
means is that we actually don't really
need to keep track of lambda right like
in a way all the complexity of lambda
all the variability that it has is fully
subsumed by this vector b that we have
here where like if we knew b we could
always compute lambda whenever we want
just by by evaluating the future map if
we wanted to
like unlike all the data inside of
lambda is kind of like stored instead of
b and note that b is a vector in r in
our d like b is a is a low dimensional
vector of course right so like being
like the image of the future map means
that like the the space in which you
start is easily dimensional
right so again so this means that we
actually
do not really need to perform line five
explicitly we can just you know just
like do the you know compute these bts
which are like simple to compute given
the history and line five you can forget
about it
but of course you know if you forget
about line five and we don't really
store explicitly the lambdas you know
how can we evaluate lane three with only
blist access to lambda b right like now
we're storing b instead of lambda but
how do we do line three where we know we
have to do the sum that depends on
number
and this is where the second idea comes
in the idea is that at all times t you
can prove that lambda is proportional to
the feature map sorry uh
you can prove that x t can be
reconstructed from b using this formula
right and and the
you know like the the important thing
like forget about like exactly what the
vectors are inside of this uh this
formula but you know like it's it uses d
plus one kernel evaluations you have one
for each numerator right like you have
this kind of evaluation for the first
dimension and you know like one bridge
dimension until the last one and then
the denominator is always the same right
the denominator is always a kernel
evaluation between bt and one and the
vector one right so we only need d plus
one kernel evaluations and the idea for
the proof is it's not too complicated it
extends a very beautiful insight of
taking more information
so you know like when you put together
these two pieces you know like you don't
really need to store lambda anymore you
can just store the bs and you don't
really need like in line three which was
kind of like the complicated convex
combination we have a close formula now
that only depends on the kernel so you
can just like simulate exactly vertex mw
by using this algorithm on the right
which is kernel mw kernel smw
okay so this is kind of like you know
like the i guess like the main
like result of the paper
is only saying that
it takes d plus one evaluations
but depending on your polytope it might
not be easy to compute that term so
that's why we're going to talk now about
actually we're going to be done we're
going to be doing exchange from games
and um
in excessive form games the idea is not
too complicated
um any particular
like the kernel of
omega for example games can be evaluated
in time linear in the number of edges of
the true form decision problem which
also means that kernelized optimistic
multiplicative weights can be
implemented with quadratic time per
iteration it's quadratic time because we
need the d plus one evaluations of the
kernel at every iteration and now the
theorem that i gave you at the top says
that each evaluation uh depends kind of
like cos linear in g right like we have
d squared kind of dependence where d
is the dimension of the positive which
happens to be the number of edges in the
in the decision problem like in the in
the three form decision problem right so
but at least with this theorem that we
have at the top you you already get a
polynomial implementation and then i'll
show you that we can do better uh just
like let me show you a little bit of the
of the idea as to how it works basically
the idea is that the sequence from
strategy spaces have a strong bottom-up
combinatorial structure uh that you can
kind of characterize using precision
products and convex cells and
effectively what we do is that we
exploit the commentary structure by
introducing some forms like partial
kernels for subtrees and then at every
decision point in the tree form decision
problem uh but what we have is that the
kernel for the subtree rooted at that
decision point is kind of like a
weighted sum of kernels for each of the
child sub trees and then for every
substrate that instead is rooted at the
observation point we have a product of
kernels right so we have this kind of
like nice bottom-up computation for
extension from games right this can like
the intuition that's how it works the
details are always like you know just
like complicated with like a lot of
notation about trees but this is
fundamentally the idea we have product
and sounds
sorry
but there is another player i mean
there's incompleteness
if you look at just one player at a time
uh you can define some like strategy
space only for itself right and the the
perfect information just like comes
naturally from what the observation
points are like if they cannot observe
something that the observation point
will just have less signals that doesn't
affect that they know the problem right
right that doesn't affect anything right
yeah so you can just assume that this
kind of like three forms of problems
already
for all the players uh and then every
player just has like their own set and
they will do online learning on that one
yeah but that that's a good question
that's always one of the tricky things
with excessive from characters like
going from
the game to where all the players are
kind of like in the same game versus
kind of like the online learning kind of
like
one player at the time point of view and
seeing what the strategy states is
but you know like just like from i guess
like at least this is like situation
this gives a linear time bottom of
competition of the kernel
um and like i said you know like this
gives immediately quadratic time
graduation and decision tree size but
can we do better than quadratic
iterations and if you remember at all
times t
the iterate that we need to output can
be reconstructed from the b vector using
this kind of complicated formula but you
know like the kernel evaluations that
you need they have a lot of kind of like
structure right they all take bt as the
first vector and there's always like a
one minus
like an indicator vector and then in the
denominator there's always btn1 so the
question is can we amortize the cost of
computing those d plus one kernels for
example instead of paying quadratic time
we can just reuse information and maybe
do it in linear time and the answer is
yes so we can implement kernelized omw
with linear time per iteration in
decision tree size by amortizing the
complexity of the d plus one kernel
evaluations by reusing intermediate
computations
which you know like in summary what it
says is that in extensive form games
kernelized omw guarantees all these
things it has linear time iterations
polygamic regret when used by all
players in the extent from games and
this is like the first time that it's
shown that this is possible uh with you
know just like efficient iterations uh
it has more favorable regret bounds than
all prior known extensive from game
algorithms which you know surprised at
the time and you know like it is also
future proof like we said if somebody
tomorrow comes up with a better analysis
of optimistic multiplicity with update
for uh normal form games then we narrate
all the like all the improvements
directly
so with that you know like let me just
like quickly wrap up you know we
introduced this kernel on wu it
simulates running mw on the vertices of
a zero one polyhedral set and it does it
in a like black box function fashioned
by
uh having access to this uh kernel
uh oracle or like kernel function now
the kernel function can be validated in
linear time in the sense of the true
form decision problem in extensive form
games this is true for all players
uh it you know in essence from games it
defies this kind of like long-held
common wisdom about uh the fact that you
shouldn't actually computationally you
know like be thinking about converting
extension games into normal from games
but like it completely shows that that
actually is not really accurate and in
fact not only there are benefits in
terms of you know like this polygraphy
convergence uh like
polygon regret and like therefore
accelerated convergence to course
correct equilibrium but also it leads to
new state-of-the-art regret bounds and
if you want it's also kind of like uh i
think i think at least to me you know
like it's it's a very fundamental
geometric fact about this extension
games like i feel like this should have
been known right like the fact that the
vertices have such a structure that you
can
like simulate running optimistic
multiplicative weights inaccessible
games directly without having to come up
with a different method
right there's also other sets for which
the kernel can be validated efficiently
in the paper we have like especially in
appendix like uh like a few sections
the unit hypercube is kind of simple uh
right like if you have a unit hypercube
then the vertices are basically this
like set zero one to the to the
dimension and you know like if you just
take the definition of the kernel it's
it's easy to see combinatorially that
you can evaluate it in linear time by
just using this formula
uh if you have a set of flows in the dag
you can do dynamic programming on the
topological sorting of the of the nodes
to compute the kernel efficiently if you
have double double stochastic matrices
you can do some form of approximate
computations that that can actually
improve that exact is hard
if you have n sets
you can compute the kernel using dynamic
programming in linear time
uh spanning trees another
communitarial set for which we have
efficient kernel computation and the
other nice thing is that in many cases
actually criminalized omw unifies
existing approaches for some of these
kind of domains
um
you know under this kind of unified
framework of like kernelized omw
you know we're especially i think in
depth to the work by talking about
warmth on path kernels for graphs uh for
some of the precursor work
um you know like i feel like
it's fair to say that the kernel that we
use in criminalized mw can be seen as a
significant generalization of uh their
path kernels for dags uh for example in
games things are
more complicated than paths on tax
because we have observation points which
can like increase the flow uh of
probability if that makes sense to like
if you're if you're familiar with
sensible games if not it doesn't matter
but like you know there are like some
complications but you know i think
without taking modern warmouth it's
unclear if we would have been able to
uh complete some of the the pieces that
we're missing
um
and yeah and let me also mention a
couple of open questions uh right like
all of the work so far uh needed to
assume zero one important vertices at
different key points in the proof can we
somehow develop a more advanced kernel
function that can work for um you know
just like general politics or even maybe
like not even positive i mean who knows
right like maybe you can kernelize way
more than positives
um and then the second question is well
you know like criminalized optimistic
multiplicative weights shows this
algorithmic regret for extensive games
which is a setting we care a lot about
but you know there might be more general
complex games that we care about where
this technology you know like it is not
viable which is maybe because the kernel
is too expensive or or maybe it's not
even a polytube so uh you know there's
even more hurdles so i guess there's
like this other kind of like general
second question can your ultimate regret
bounce be guaranteed for general
uh convex games right like beyond
extensive games
so that that's all i had i'm happy to
you know take questions i i know if they
were like anyone like on the chat on
zoom okay perfect yeah otherwise uh yeah
thanks
[Applause]
awesome thanks a lot that's a really
nice work uh are there any questions
right now
i can do just like a base oh okay noah
has a question well actually i'll i'll
just do a quick question first which is
just like uh so i asked for the first
question up here
so it's classically right kind of like
as coasters was mentioning earlier you
know
there's this approach to handling
combinatorial action sets which is doing
kind of like follow the perturbed leader
right and what does that require that
requires that i can kind of do like
linear optimization
over my uh you know over my decision set
right
so like
when we talk about going beyond zero one
coordinate vertices is there any hope of
getting something that works kind of
like at that level of generality or do
you think that's like too much to ask
for
that's a good question i think there is
a little bit more that can be done um i
think we toyed at some point with like
some form like weighted kernel where
basically there was like an exponent for
example that depended on the the entry
in the vertex obviously like
you you're like you map
vectors low dimensional into vectors
high dimensional uh where you can do
vertex specific things and if the vertex
for example had i don't know like a zero
one or a two then we needed to get that
square for example
um so i think a little bit more can be
done but it's not really clear that we
have a general
for sure yeah
well okay i'll go uh take it over to
noah
at least um do you have any ideas about
how to extend this to like efcce or efce
that's uh something that i've been
thinking about i don't really
think we are quite there yet but a lot
of this machinery extends in that
direction
let's see okay let me run over here
there's something about amy
okay
um
this is maybe a little bit far out there
but
your initial sort of observation that
you can transform an extensive form game
to a normal forum game something similar
i guess holds for a markov game where
you could sort of take a step back and
view your strategy space as the space of
all possible
policies in the markov game
do you see there being a similar trick
in that setting as you're doing here
i don't like that that's a question
that's something that we wondered as
well um but i i i don't know that
anybody has looked into that yet so but
that that's that's a good question okay
the month of can require number
one was wondering about this as well um
yeah there's another question from amy
in the chat which is another thing that
i was also wondering about which is like
uh yeah can you say a little bit about
uh to what extent this approach extends
to kind of like other variants of mirror
descent beyond multiplicative weights
i see
that for example like with a euclidean
regular yeah i mean like
or even just like you know some
regularizer right i see i feel like this
really fundamentally relies on the
multiplicative kind of like structure
that is given by the
like the entropic regularizer so for
example like if you did omg with
quadratic regularization which is
fundamentally like projected gradient
descent um i don't think you can do this
but but i know i might be wrong guys you
know
sounds good
let's see are there any other questions
all right maybe we should stop it there
let's uh thank gabriel again thanks
so we'll take a quick break and then
we'll be back at uh 11 30 for the last
session of the morning